mesdames et messieurs bonsoir trois
otages libérés
nous avons vécu à propos des événements
de lire une journée dramatique à
diverses reprises nous avons eu des
informations disant que certains otages
de l'ambassade des etats-unis à téhéran
al et être libres qu'ils étaient sur le
point d'être libéré que c'était imminent
que ce n'était qu'une question de
secondes
il ya trente minutes nous avons enfin
une confirmation trois otages trois
seulement sont sortis de l'ambassade
trois seulement alors qu'on en attendait
une dizaine au moins je vous ai résumé
des dépêches notre envoyé spécialà
terrain philippe rochot va je l'espère
nous apporter d'autres précisions plus
optimistes libérés ont fait leur entrée
dans la cour de l'ambassade américaine
les donneurs des étudiants islamiques
si chanter l'atmosphère était très
tendue des bleus noirs américains qu'on
nous a présentés semblait très marqué en
revanche la femme souriait qu'on parlait
sous les flots bahati américains et les
portraits d'euros mais ils ont dit
qu'ils avaient été bien traités sur
regrettait ce qui s'était passé croyait
en la révolution iranienne et le sort
des otages qui restent prisonniers des
étudiants islamiques
c'est inquiétant ce sera un procès
public
s'ils sont reconnus coupables on ne leur
appliquera pas de chasse mans clanique
puisqu'ils ne sont pas musulmans elle en
irak
l'espionnage épuiserait venez de prison
de toute manière on a l'impression dans
le bas dir la certitude que dans cette
affaire de prise d'otages les ordres de
lettres l'arménie n'ont pas été toujours
suivi par les étudiants ainsi comme eni
avait annoncé pas plus tard qu hier que
toutes les femmes et que toutes les
personnes noires seraient libérés or il
n'y ait que trois otages libérés cet
aspect de compte gouttes ainsi que le
retard dans la libération peut vouloir
indiquer que les étudiants islamiques
entendent montrer au pouvoir de fait au
pouvoir entre guillemets officiel qu'ils
sont devenus eux aussi eu les étudiants
un véritable pouvoir
voici l'homme qui diffusait la bonne
parole de l'ayatollah khomeiny en iran
quand le guide suprême était en exil en
irak et à paris c'est là y est la charia
tu m'as d'harry le plus populaire des
chefs religieux
le numéro deux dans la hiérarchie des
musulmans chiites en iran après la
lettre la robine aujourd'hui c'est la
fête de rats dire qu'ils marquent que
l'étape du voyage de mahomet vers médine
où il désigna ali comme son successeur
l'occasion pour ces paysans venus du
nord de prêter serment de fidélité à
leur chef spirituel pour les pauvres les
déshérités
les oubliés du régime impérial ses
hommes en turban sont encore des demi
dieux
la coutume veut que chaque année on leur
apporte les jeunes enfants pour qu'ils
les bénisse ce simple geste dans la
tradition apporte à la famille
longue vie et nombreuses postérité
la crise entre l'iran et les etats-unis
a pourtant profondément divisé le
mouvement religieux pour ne pas perdre
cette popularité
les religieux ont souvent dû faire de la
surenchère face aux mouvements
populaires
l'ayatollah mahdavi lui est un modéré
il a toujours freiné khomeiny dans ses
déclarations de guerre la crise entre
l'iran et les états unis
il préfère ne pas en parler la guerre du
pétrole il ne l'approuvent pas l'iran
dit il doit continuer de produire du
pétrole car il en a besoin pour son
économie
quand il aura satisfait ses besoins
économiques il pourra alors réduire sa
production pétrolière la sphère de
l'ambassade des états unis aura servi au
moins à canaliser l'opposition sur la
lutte anti américaine
les chefs religieux ont tenté de
récupérer le mouvement que l'on a dit
spontanée pour ne pas être débordé les
voici en délégation à la sortie de
l'ambassade américaine où ils sont venus
apporter leur soutien aux étudiants et
prendre un bain de foule c'est
l'ayatollah chrome chailly qui parle
il dira que les américains ont toujours
sucer le sang des nations les plus
pauvres que carter est un criminel il
dire enfin que les américains ont volé
nos pétrodollars pendant 30 ans ils nous
ont donné de la ferraille inutile à la
place et pour les étudiants c'est
toujours le mouvement populaire qui
conduit l'iran et cette campagne anti
américaine aura finalement servi à
rectifier la ligne politique de la
révolution iranienne est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que maintenant
l'ayatollah khomeini est un peu dépassé
par les événements
et dépasser non pour aussi longtemps que
le peuple est derrière c'est le cas en
tout cas pour la masse populaire et
dépasser non mais il faut que a été leur
khomeiny harry pour finir choisir des
hommes de la situation et c'est ça qui
est très difficile et pourtant c'est
toujours le portrait de l'ayatollah
khomeini que l'on brandit dans les rues
religieux ou pas il reste pour les
iraniens
l'homme qui a renversé le régime
impérial mais la crise avec les états
unis ne va-t-elle pas aggraver la
situation économique de l'iran et
provoquer de nouveaux mécontentement une
bonne partie des iraniens qui avait
placé tous leurs espoirs dans le
mouvement islamique sont aujourd'hui
déçus jusque là le nouveau régime a
toujours pu canaliser leur colère sur
des objectifs précis
mes deux mains des iraniens seront de
nouveau face aux réalités
si dans le cours de cette émission j'ai
d'autres informations de terrain jordan
est naturellement la priorité en
belgique à hannut trois personnes dont
un enfant ont été tués et une dizaine
d'autres blessées par un déséquilibré
qui a ouvert le feu sur les spectateurs
qui assistaient à une épreuve de
cross-country
un homme blessé dans une foule
une femme qui peut être survivre à un
enfant tué par balle que l'on évacué par
ambulance sur un stade de belgique
accident de parcours dans la vie dans le
labyrinthe de la psychiatrie drame des
autres parce qu'ailleurs et pourtant si
près d'ici celui qui a donné la mort en
belgique au hasard de sa vie comme on
dit était en traitement psychiatrique
il a tué trois personnes dont un enfant
spectateurs d'un cross country et blessé
une dizaine de personnes la foule a
voulu le lyncher le lyncher pourquoi
pour qui pour sa folie pour sa tuerie
qui illustre pour ce pensionnaire
bénéficiant d'une permission de sortie
le drame dit des autres simplement sans
doute celui de la vie la sienne
étrangers toujours le pape jean paul ii
effectuera une visite en turquie dans
une dizaine de jours du 28 au 30
novembre
le saint père se rendra à ankara la
capitale puis à izmir la blanche et à
istanbul espagne on est toujours sans
nouvelles de monsieur javier perez
conseiller du président de gai
même en espagnol mais ce soir s et qui
fut d'enlever dimanche dernier à madrid
par un commando de l'organisation basque
l'été à politico militaire la violence
et les actes de terrorisme qu'ils ont
fait je vous le rappelle plus de 120
morts en espagne depuis le début de
cette année ont été violemment critiqué
ce matin à madrid dans les faits les
nostalgiques du franquisme s'étaient
rassemblés pour célébrer le quatrième
anniversaire de la mort du général
franco manifestation désormais
traditionnelle qui a regroupé les
représentants de nombreux partis
d'extrême droite espagnol français et
italien ni mauvaise nouvelle pour le
sénateur kennedy qui voudrait être le
candidat du parti démocrate pour
l'élection présidentielle
un producteur de cinéma américain va
réaliser en effet un film sur la sphère
de chappaquiddick il s'agit vous vous le
rappeler j'en suis sûr de l'épisode
tragique au cours duquel la secrétaire
de monsieur kennedy avait trouvé la mort
à la suite d'un accident de voiture
alors que les sénateurs lui même était
au volant
le film dont le tournage est nous dit-on
déjà en cours sortira figurez-vous au
mois de juillet juillet c'est à dire une
semaine avant l'ouverture de la
convention démocrate laquelle désignera
officiellement le candidat de ce parti
pour l'élection à la maison blanche pour
l'instant et dans un rein capable de
dire qui exactement finances de file
demain à londres sommet
franco-britannique le président de la
république rencontrera en fait cher le
premier ministre conservateur depuis le
début du mois de mai l'un des points de
désaccord entre la grande bretagne et
ses partenaires de la communauté
économique européenne c'est la
contribution britannique au budget
communautaire contribution que londres
qualifie d'injuste et d'intolérables
monsieur giscard d'estaing après avoir
reçu madame thatcher cet été à paris va
donc travailler pendant deux jours avec
maggie comme on l'appelle là-bas une
femme pleine d'énergie et qui croit dur
comme fer à ce qu'elle fait un travail
est spécial philippe harrouard vous
présente un portrait de celle dont le
titre officiel et madame le premier
ministre du gouvernement de sa majesté
bien sûr que je doute
que margaret thatcher doute on pourrait
en douter tant ça permettait de
caractère et sa sûreté d'elle-même
domine sa personnalité maggie comme
disent les anglais et premier ministre
depuis six mois
couronnement d'une carrière étonnante
eux se défier avec intelligence de tous
les obstacles
jamais une femme ne s'est installé à
downing street
madame thatcher fils d'un modeste
épicier n'appartient pas à cette cave
aristocratique n'est pour gouverner fait
sans précédent
elle a pris la tête du parti
conservateur alors qu'elle émanait de la
minorité la plus à droite
elle est championne du libéralisme
économique capitaliste dans l'âme depuis
le début elle a su doser ambitions
détermination réalisme elle sait ce
qu'elle veut
en ces temps de crise est un atout il y
a vingt ans lorsque ces enfants sont nés
des jumeaux ses adversaires disait elle
est tellement près c'est qu'elle en a
fait deux à la fois
on aime beaucoup la reine et la vie ça
me c'est très important pas rien quand
elle était chef du parti avant de
devenir premier ministre
elle a fait le petit déjeuner chaque
matin elle a fait des us et le jambon
elle a fait la cuisine elle a fait des
emplettes
je ne sais pas comment elle a fait parce
qu'elle est un travail incroyablement
dur je n'ai jamais vu quelqu'un qui peut
travailler comme nature nature d'autres
peu très très peur sans fils m'a dit
qu'elle est la dame qui ne dort jamais
jamais jamais mais évidemment elle
dormait 3h04 coq voire cinq
chaque soir et elle a travaillé dans une
usine
parce que quand elle était à
l'université l étudier l'art subit un
avocat aussi quand elle s'est mariée
elle a refait la loire chez elle
les anglais ont vraiment appris à la
connaître pendant la campagne électorale
elle fonce elle parle elle charme ce
qu'elle dit fait mouche
l'état c'est à dire le contribuable paie
trop et à tout propos
les syndicats sont trop puissants les
grèves trop nombreuses il faut y
remédier six mois après
que pensent les anglais de leur premier
ministre je crois qu'il le juge quand
même avec respect sinon avec affection
bien que pas du tout c'est parce que
tout le monde soit d'accord avec sa
politique je crois que la politique en
tant que telle est moins populaire qu'au
moment de l'élection mais les gens sont
frappés par le fait qu'elle persiste
qu'elle fait plus ou moins exactement ce
qu'elle avait dit qu'il ferait donc il y
a une certaine consistance dans la
politique et ça ça impressionne quand
même les gens un cheval de bataille pour
madame thatcher qu'elle expose ici c'est
la contribution versée par londres à la
communauté européenne près d'un milliard
l'an prochain c'est insupportable dit
elle il faut modifier les règles
communautaires ses partenaires dont la
france estime que c'est à la grande
bretagne de changer d'attitude ses liens
commerciaux avec le commonwealth la
pénalise mais à qui la faute
ce dossier sera plaidé à dublin à la fin
du mois évoquée dès demain avec le
président giscard d'estaing madame
thatcher devra leur concilier fermeté et
souplesse car pour elle l' affaire est
délicate
cela dit c'est ce problème ne peut être
résolu que par un compromis j'ai pas
qu'il est hors de question que
l'angleterre obtiennent tout ce qu'elle
demande
mais je crois qu'il faut il faudra bien
qu'elle obtienne quelque chose et je
pense que monsieur giscard d'estaing qui
a des options politiques plus ou moins
comparable à celle de madame sacha et
qui a l'air de lui souhaiter du bien il
a tout à fait intérêt à faire un peu de
chemin
pour lui faciliter la tâche dans la
politique intérieure
demain leur émission questions de camp
de jean pierre elkabbach rue bériault
traitera d'un sujet de très hautes
actualité la situation en israël avec
entre autres la contestation à l'égard
du premier ministre monsieur ennjimi
dans cette émission présentée d'israël
vous verrez des reportages de jacques
bouchard et paul nahon et celui ci va
vous dire maintenant comment ce
programme a été conçu avec comme invité
d'honneur monsieur weizman qui sera
peut-être le prochain chef du
gouvernement israël il nous a paru
important
deux ans après le voyage du président
sadate à jérusalem de faire à nouveau le
point sur les négociations de paix au
proche-orient et nous avons choisi pour
ce spécial question de temps d'évoquer à
travers israël ces négociations de paix
justement au moment où le pays traverse
une nouvelle crise politique économique
crise économique avec 100 % d'inflation
par an avec paradoxalement alors que la
paix est signé entre l'egypte et israël
des dépenses militaires accrues pour
redéployer l'armée malienne qui a évacué
vous le savez le sinaly crise politique
avec un premier ministre contesté avec
au sein du gouvernement les partisans
des colonies sauvages installé en tête
occupée et avec surtout il ya quelques
jours la démission collective des mers
arabes de cisjordanie qui entendent
protester par la contre l'expulsion et
l'emprisonnement de l'un de leurs
collègues
le maire de naplouse monsieur chaque
dans cette émission également nous
questionnerons longuement l'un des
hommes clés du gouvernement israélien le
ministre la défense monsieur ezer
weizman considéré là bas comme un modéré
si vous voulez une colombe en tout cas
l'homme avec qui le président sadate a
toujours préféré de tous temps négocié
pour beaucoup également monsieur réservé
ce man se pose en candidat très sérieux
à la succession de monsieur mais la
reine begin peut-être demain un futur
premier ministre
en tout cas donc lundi spécial question
de temps à 20h30 sur antenne de france
une nouvelle candidature pour les
élections présidentielles aujourd'hui
c'est madame huguette bouchardeau
secrétaires nationales du psg c'est la
première femme inscrite dans la
compétition alain bouchard d'eau et
agrégé de philosophie et elle est maire
de 3 en clôture à versailles de la
convention des clubs perspectives des
réalités selon leur président jean
pierre fourcade
en dépit du caractère outrancier de
beaucoup de polémiques la société où
nous vivons est plus proche de la vérité
le consensus que d'une disco grave et
dans un message à la convention le
premier ministre monsieur raymond barre
a félicité des clubs perspectives et
réalités d'affronter je cite les sujets
essentiels avec lucidité sans recours
aux artifices ou illusion que suggère le
goût de la facilité la plus ancienne
organisation 1-6 du monde la nique à la
ligue internationale contre
l'antisémitisme
réunis en congrès ce week end à paris a
décidé d'ajouter une lettre à son nom
elle devient la ligue internationale
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme
autrement dit là elle qui sert à la
licra au lieu de lalique
elle veut montrer ainsi qu'elle est
contre tous les racismes quel qu'il soit
madame simone veil a présidé la fin du
congrès de la licra et monsieur lozès
les rues secrétaires d'état auprès du
ministre du travail a expliqué aux
congressistes
la position du gouvernement dans le
domaine des travailleurs chimiques
messieurs françois mitterrand premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste était
l'invité ce soir du club de la presse en
europe numéro un
l'émission n'est pas terminé de ce qu'a
dit monsieur mitterrand j'extrais le
passage où il a dit qu'à son avis le
pétrole n'est pas à l'origine des
difficultés économiques toi si cet
extrait pensons pas qu'il soit sain qui
soit juste et même qu'il soit honnête de
faire reposer lançant de l'analyse
économique quant au déficit du budget
quant aux difficultés du fromage des
graves difficultés du chômage
quant à la hausse des prix par exemple
sur l'augmentation du pétrole lorsque le
pétrole et a suivi le train et on
pourrait faire la démonstration que le
prix du pétrole s'il n'était pas
surchargé par les taxes qui font que sur
3 francs 0,5 ou 0,6 de super il ya deux
france pax en réalité le pétrole à
l'origine et comme cela a déjà été dit
coûte pas plus cher que certaines
bouteilles un litre d'eau minérale et
prétendre que le pétrole est celui qui
est se démolit l'économie française hier
c'est la faute aux autres
c'est mentir aux français
l'augmentation du pétrole ne pèse pas
pour 2% sur une augmentation des prix
qui atteindra peut-être 12% cette année
alors ça sont des choses qu'il faut dire
les gouvernants n'ont pas tiré les
conséquences de ce qui s'est produit
notre confrère l'est républicain fait
paraître aujourd'hui en supplément du
dimanche
les résultats du questionnaire présenté
à 3000 lecteurs qui voulait jouer les
jurys littéraires questions posées parmi
les 77 prix goncourt attribué depuis la
création du prix quels sont les trois
que vous préférez alors en pet
les lecteurs ont classé andré malraux
pour la condition humaine puis maurice
genevoix pour raboliot et emile ajar
pour la vie devant sma ne trouverez dans
l'est républicain dimanche l'analyse de
ce classement très instructif et
d'autres réalise qu'on se dirige par
tranche d'âge des lecteurs le prix
goncourt 79 sera attribué demain à paris
chez drouant le goncourt est un
véritable phénomène économique le tirage
du livre primé atteint plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'exemplaires
bref le prix le prix le plus important
de l'année et celui qui soulève il faut
bien le dire le plus de passion alain
gillot-pétré va commencer son enquête
sur le prix goncourt par les lieux mêmes
des délibérations le salon goncourt
passe question c'est sous le portrait
des demandes boncourt que ça va
attribuer lundi prochain le 76e prix
goncourt traditionnellement cela a lieu
le troisième lundi 2 novembre chez
trépardoux c'est vous qui servit les
monts cours de 10 et 20 ans comment se
compose la table bien vous occuper la
place du président monsieur hervé bazin
ce normal à sa droite il est malade mal
je ris la vice présidente
ensuite monsieur tournier monsieur
robles monsieur salacrou
cela nous serait en général oui monsieur
nourricier monsieur style monsieur
cayrol et monsieur sabbatique en charge
mais ça ne changeait mais chacun à sa
place elle est immuable le vote des
goncourt signifie pour un auteur le
succès et la gloire tirage moyen du prix
au moins cent cinquante mille
exemplaires on comprend que les éditeurs
se battent pour obtenir un tel prix
faisons quelques statistiques en vingt
ans sur 20 prix goncourt neuf sont
revenus à gallimard 3 à grasset 3 au
seuil case prix sur 20 pour celles que
l'on appelle le trio infernal gallimard
grasset le seuil pour bernard clavel
l'ancien académicien ce quasi monopole
est le fait des jurés c'est une chose
qu'on peut lire tous les ans dans les
journaux qu'on entend à toutes les
radios et on a l'impression de découvrir
aujourd'hui une vérité et moi c'est une
vérité que je connaissais avant d'entrer
à l'académie goncourt
j'ai pensé j'ai espéré que peut-être on
pouvait arriver y remédier
j'ai vu que ça n'était pas possible mais
je ne pense pas que qui que ce soit soit
acheté ou vendu là dedans dit simplement
pour des raisons de peut-être d'amitié
d'affection
parce que des auteurs appartiennent à
une maison d'édition
ils votent systématiquement pour des
poulains de ces maisons d'édition et ça
c'est une chose que je n'ai pas pu
supporter c'est pourquoi j'ai quitté
l'académie goncourt
quant à un membre d'un jury et romancier
évidemment il ya un éditeur alors
heureusement clavel ne parle pas de
corruption ni d' enveloppe mais enfin il
peut y avoir des influences des
affinités si on a choisi un éditeur
c'est parce que on se sent chez soi avec
lui alors on peut préférer sa production
alors le remède à cela
il est évident et il est appliqué c'est
que les jurys composent une espèce de
cocktail très divers de maisons
d'édition je peux vous dire qu'à
l'académie en cours par exemple sont
représentés six ou sept éditeurs alors
dit clavel pourquoi sont toujours les
mêmes conditions qui ont les grands prix
écouter quels sont les même si on dit
gallimard le seuil grasset c'est un
petit peu comme si pour l'automobile on
disait
peugeot renault citroën ça représente
70% de la production littéraire en
france ça n'est pas étonnant que ce soit
à cela cai très souvent les prix
pourtant cette année les choses semblent
changer on dit que l'académie goncourt
serait prêt à sortir du trio infernal
gallimard grasset le seuil
alors lundi prochain qui le retournement
de vladimir volkoff pélagie la charrette
d'antonine maillet mozy ou le lézard qui
pleurait dîner ce cagnati outils jean
l'horizon de simone schwarz bart qui la
seule chose sûre pour le moment c'est le
menu
il vient le déjeuner commencé avec un
béluga de la caspienne et du caviar
c'est du caviar et puis le foie gras des
landes en lob à la gelée
ensuite le marbrier de rouen qui sera
suivie d'une gigue de chevreuil 5 et
beurre crème de marron le fromage et
puis le décès à ce sera un sorbet aux
fruits de la passion avec des
mignardises sorbet aux fruits de la
passion littéraire bien sûr oui mais ce
sera à la fin du repas
et ouais c'est gus gus et sa verve son
crayon quelquefois très dur et sa voix
qui paraît paisible mais où passent des
nuances qui en disent long
bus a choisi lui-même pour ce soir
dimanche les meilleurs parmi les dessins
qui nous a donné tout au long de la
semaine qui vient de s'écouler à
l'édition de batteurs du journalisme
lundi orléans
j'ai été réglée par un chèque douteux la
police appuient sur cette déclaration
d'un pompiste déclenché des recherches
l'ordinateur perreur appuie les soupçons
il s'agit d'une voiture volée s'appuyant
sur ce verdict et policiers prennent la
voiture en chasse un policier trop
nerveux appuyé sur la détente
résultat un innocent grièvement blessé
mardi le monde en a le souffle coupé
l'ayatollah khomeini affronte le joueur
international le plus riche dans une
partie de poker terrifiante ce qu'on
appelle un jeu d'en faire ce qui crée
des bleus qui n'osera pas aller au bout
des surenchères
mais allez donc savoir avec un homme qui
méprise les règles du jeu mercredi le
rpr ne votera pas une motion de censure
contre le gouvernement
on pourrait en déduire que la confiance
continue à régner au sein de la majorité
ce serait trop saint jacques chirac et
ses amis s'apprêtent à porter des coups
sévères à la politique de raymond barre
ça n'empêche absolument pas les
sentiments jeudi le problème de la
formation des policiers continuer à
préoccuper l'opinion
à ce propos le journal d'antenne 2
diffuse un reportage de jean jacques
dufour c'est l'école de police anglaise
on en retire l'impression qu'on y forme
essentiellement exemple nous que des
malfaiteurs aurait plaisir à retrouver
autour d'une tasse de thé vendredi
températures en dents de scie pour le
voyage du président de la république
dans la région midi-pyrénées applaudi
ici chahuté ailleurs
valéry giscard d'estaing reste
impassible et souriant dans les
intempéries ne fait confiance au bon
roman de robert fabre pharmaciens et
député maire de villefranche de rouergue
j'ai une dépêche
arrivé à l'inter 17 juillet il ya sept
ou huit minutes seulement de washington
une dépêche afp dix ans que le
département d'état c'est à dire le
ministère américain des affaires
étrangères ne possédait aucune
information supplémentaire à propos de
la libération des otages par laquelle
nous avons commencé cette vision du
journal est en tout cas il semble bien
que l'on s'attendait à washington à ce
que douze personnes au moins
fut-ce libérer un bref voyage pour nosy
lava elles forment l'un des états des
états unis d'amérique mais elles sont au
beau milieu de l'océan pacifique et
quelques 5000 km des côtes du continent
américain
c'est un bail que se trouvera un élu et
ses paysages de rêve
pearl harbour et sa fameuse base
militaire bombardée par les japonais
redescend au 41 et partout des volcans
il ya huit îles principales
elles sont toutes volcanique avec certes
un volcan qui culmine à plus de 4000
mètres
ouais si l'éruption de l'inde ces
volcans cela nous vaut des images
saisissantes et que l'on peut regarder
d'un oeil d'autant plus calme qu'il n'y
a eu aucune victime
hawaï est en effet la plus importante
des îles de l'archipel du même nom elle
est située à 50 km de la ville de hilo
c'est ici qu'a eu lieu cette subite
éruptions volcaniques
par mesure de précaution toutes les
routes environnantes ont été interdites
à la circulation la dernière éruption
volcanique de ce type dans cet archipel
remonte à une dizaine d'années
a auteuil le tiercé été visité par
terrain très lourd
il a vu certaines arrivées un cheval
très indiqué ken hill le cap
le gagnant mais aussi deux haltes
seibert et pierrette brès vous avez
donné ce tiercé sans ordre mais c'est
déjà très bien
la course était difficile dans les
pronostics que je vous ai communiqué
hier soir de sa part un résumé de la
course en gagnant le prix cambacérès la
grande course de haies des 3 yanka chine
il a confirmé qu'il était le meilleur de
sa génération il fallait tenir 3600
mètres et sauté aux obstacles claude
dugas son jockey économiser au maximum
et ne prit la tête du peloton qu'à la
moitié du parcours caché ni de kiné à
détacher en soutien ensemble avant
dernier et celui de prince samir
hypothermie à sorrento et waikiki qui se
rapproche très forts physiques âge elle
est jolie yard sont tombés pour sauter
la dernièr e et k chine il a maintenant
deux longueurs d'avancé white ils
attaquent courageusement cachemire qui
saute la perfection se lance maintenant
vers le poteau d'arrivée ne laissant
aucune chance à waikiki de le rattraper
sorento l'outsider de la course qui
possède une bonne pointe de 8,7 l'efs
réussi à se rapprocher et a conservé la
troisième place derrière cas chenil et
white kiki l'arrivée du tiercé sera 4 11
quatre ans 12 déjà été d'autant plus
heureux de vous donner les rapports
puisque pires toute la donne et sans
abri hier mais nous n'avons pas encore
communication des rapports sans doute
parce qu'il y avait un non partant et
aussi parce qu'il y a l'un des shows
favoris à l'arrivée
vous l'aurez sûrement pour notre
élection de 23 heures
n'allez pas américaine les marines
tiennent à peu près le rôle des
fusiliers marins chez nous mais en
dehors de leurs fonctions purement
militaire ils ont encore des tas de
vison honorifique un peu comme les
gardes républicains et ils sont vains si
souvent de service n'ont eu diffuse un
reportage de jean jacques dufour c'est
l'école de police anglaise
on en retire l'impression qu'on y forme
essentiellement des jeunes que des
malfaiteurs aurait plaisir à retrouver
autour d'une tasse de thé vendredi
températures en dents de scie pour le
voyage du président de la république
dans la région midi-pyrénées applaudi
ici chahuté ailleurs
valéry giscard d'estaing reste
impassible et souriant dans les
intempéries ne fait confiance au bon
remède de robert fabre pharmaciens et
député maire de villefranche de rouergue
j'ai une dépêche
arrivé à 20h17 hoyé il ya sept ou huit
minutes seulement de washington une
dépêche afp dix ans que le département
d'état c'est à dire le ministère
américain des affaires étrangères ne
possède aucune information
supplémentaire à propos de la libération
des otages par laquelle nous avons
commencé cette vision du journal est en
tout cas il semble bien que l'on
s'attendait à washington à ce que douze
personnes au moins
fut libéré un bref voyage pour nosy lava
elles forment l'un des états des états
unis d'amérique mais elles sont au beau
milieu de l'océan pacifique et quelques
5000 km des côtes du continent américain
c'est un bail que se trouvera un élu et
ses paysages de rêve
pearl harbour et sa fameuse base
militaire bombardée par les japonais
redescend au 41 et partout des volcans
il ya huit îles principales
elles sont toutes volcanique avec certes
un volcan qui culmine à plus de 4000
m voici l'éruption de l'indre ses voeux
le temps cela nous vaut des images
saisissantes et que l'on peut regarder
d'un oeil d'autant plus calme qu'il n'y
a eu aucune victime
hawaï est en effet la plus importante
des îles de l'archipel du même nom elle
est située à 50 km de la ville de hilo
c'est ici qu'a eu lieu cette subite
éruptions volcaniques
par mesure de précaution toutes les
routes environnantes ont été interdites
à la circulation la dernière éruption
volcanique de ce type dans cet archipel
remonte à une dizaine d'années
a auteuil le tiercé été discuté par
terrain très lourd
il a vu certains l'arrivée à cheval très
indiqué qu'elle file le cas pour le
gagnant mais aussi deux haltes cder et
pierrette brès vous avez donné ce tiercé
sans ordre mais se développe très bien
la course était difficile dans les
pronostics que je vous ai communiqué
hier soir de sa part a résumé de la
course en gagnant le prix cambacérès la
grande course de haies des 3 en
cachemire a confirmé qu'il était le
meilleur de sa génération il fallait
tenir 3600 mètres et sauté aux obstacles
claude dugas sont choqués les penno misa
au maximum et ne prit la tête du peloton
qu'à la moitié du parcours cache ni le
kiné à détacher en soutien ensemble
avant dernier et celui de prince samir
hypothermie à sorrento aywaille jpy qui
se rapproche très forts physiques âge
elle est jolie yard sont tombés pour
sauter la dernièr e et k chenil a
maintenant deux longueurs d'avancé white
ils attaquent courageusement cas chenil
qui saute la perfection se lance
maintenant vers le poteau d'arrivée ne
laissant aucune chance à waikiki de le
rattraper sorento l'outsider de la
course qui concède une bonne pointe de 8
7 aces réussis à se rapprocher et a
conservé la troisième place derrière
cash il heikki qui l'arrivée du tiercé
sera 4 11 12
quatre ans 12 joie était d'autant plus
heureux de vous donner les rapports
puisque pires tout cela donnait sans
abri hier mais nous n'avons pas encore
communication des rapports sans doute
parce qu'il y avait un non partant et
aussi parce qu'il y a l'un des shows
favoris à l'arrivée
vous l'aurez sûrement pour notre édition
de vendredi
dans les forces américaines les marines
tiennent à peu près le rôle des
fusiliers marins chez nous mais en
dehors de leurs fonctions purement
militaire ils ont fait encore des tas de
vison honorifique un peu comme les
gardes républicains et ils sont ainsi
souvent de service dans l'église
officielle et notamment les ambassades à
bari il y apprendre de marine et nous
les avons photographié alors qu'il
rendait leurs devoirs aux emblèmes pour
l'anniversaire de la fondation de leur
corps
reid
donc
non
météo demain le temps sera doux sur
l'ensemble du pays variable avec des
éclaircies et des passages nuageux ceux
ci donneront des averses notamment près
de la manche et sur les reliefs
il ya en effet de la neige au dessus de
400 m on attend de nouvelles pluies en
soirée sur l'ouest du pays
ce soir à 23h c'est hervé claude qui
vous donnera les dernières informations
de la journée
nous attendrons avec impatience comme
vous les dernières informations
concernant téhéran demain vous avez deux
rendez-vous avec l'actualité
une par antenne 2010 que vous sera
présentée par patrick lecocq et le soir
à 20 heures où vous retrouverez patrick
poivre d'arvor
bonsoir